so we expected it to happen and it
finally is my pillow ceo mike lindell
who i refer to as
mike pillow has been sued by dominion
voting systems because of his continued
and persistent
bogus weaponized election fraud claims
mike lindell
is a right-wing pillow manufacturer
based in minnesota he mostly advertises
on
right-wing media like fox news and
newsmax and oan
or some combination of those he became
close to the president
when he showed up at the white house
relatively early in the coronavirus
pandemic
and was part of a sort of promotional
tour in which
donald trump announced that uh these
various companies that love
trump will be retooling
their factories to make n95 masks we
don't really know
if or when that actually happened but in
any case at his speech
thanking donald trump for his
involvement in making ppe
mike lindell said that he believes
donald trump is
a gift from god and it only went
downhill
from there in the post-election period
mike lindell became sort of a fixture on
right-wing media and various wacky kooky
podcasts saying
he has all the proof it was stolen by
joe biden and dominion voting systems
was a big part of it
he will now have to mount a legal
defense and if he really does have the
proof
that dominion did whatever it is he
thinks they did in the 2020 election
he's going to get the chance to prove it
because that's what you get to do in
defamation
cases dominion is seeking more than 1.3
billion dollars in damages
the lawsuit says that mike lindell quote
exploited
false claims about election fraud to
support
his company's sales and mike lindell has
responded by saying quote
i'm very happy that they've done this
i'm ready to go
to court i have all the evidence that
anyone
would ever want to see now you might
remember that in an interview with the
new york times
uh last month early february i believe
it was in january
lindell said he welcomes a lawsuit from
dominion they had sent him a sort of
legal letter
warning him if you don't stop we will
sue and we might sue anyway
and they have sued and i guess we'll see
how it all works out for mike pillow now
this is going to be
mike pillow this is going to be
fascinating
because as has been the issue with
defamation lawsuits for a long time
defamation statutes have been a thing
for a while
proving that what you said is true is a
valid defense to defamation
if mike pillow's allegations are true
it is by definition not defamation
defamation can take two forms slander or
libel
slander is a spoken defamation
libel is written defamation if mike
pillow
can prove that dominion voting systems
and again it's hard to understand what
he even claims but if mike pillow can
prove that they did whatever he claims
that they did
he would be off scot-free and wouldn't
be liable
for anything now i love the idea of
mike having to go to court with his
so-called evidence but
my guess is if i had to bet on it
that whatever lawyers mike lindell
actually hires are going to tell him
mike the way to fight this is not to go
to court and try to prove
voter fraud i can't imagine any serious
lawyer
would even take this case if the
strategy is going to be we're going to
go in there and prove
that dominion did whatever it is mike
lindell claims that they did it will
either be pled out or settled
mike lindell might end up apologizing
like alex jones has about i think it was
chobani yogurt or something like that
and it actually reminds me of if you
think back to
not that long ago trump's second
impeachment his first
uh cadre of lawyers quit
and one of the bits of of
news that we got around that was that
trump wanted that
first slate of attorneys to defend trump
by proving the election was stolen
therefore
legitimizing or legitimating yes that's
a word
legitimizing the um uh
inciting of the riot and reportedly
trump's first slate of lawyers said
that's a crazy idea
uh word that doesn't make sense they
ended up parting ways
but ultimately trump's legal team did
not defend him by saying
the election was stolen they defended
him by saying he didn't actually incite
the riot
so um we will follow this remember that
rudy giuliani has also been sued by
dominion voting systems
and we're going to follow it and see
where this ultimately ends up
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and five-year
warranty they'll give you fifteen
percent off everything in their store
and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman